[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg ein weiterer heißer juli
abend willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
die vom sport hat
wir haben unter anderem diese themen für
sie
die eu-kommission will gas einsparen im
notfall sollen die mitgliedsländer dazu
gezwungen werden das
schwitzen geht weiter heute vor allem im
osten deutschlands besonders hart trifft
es die die kein zuhause haben und
der regisseur dieter wedel ist tot einst
gefeiert für fernseher erfolge wie der
große bellheim dann schwer belastet
durch vergewaltigungsvorwürfe
wird morgen nach zehn tagen wartung von
nord stream 1 wieder russisches gas
durch die pipeline nach deutschland
fließen
angekündigt ist das aber so genau weiß
es keiner der russische präsident warnte
in der nacht das auch deutlich weniger
kommen könne russland nutze gas wie eine
waffe und erpresse die eu sagt
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen und
präsentierte heute einen notfallplan
damit die eu für den fall eines
lieferstopps über den winter kommt aus
brüssel gunnar krüger die eu will weg
von russlands gas das klima der krieg
gründe gibt es genug dazu kommt nun die
knappheit die putin schafft die eu
kommission sagt darum wer wie gas sparen
sollte börsting der member states wir
fordern die mitgliedstaaten auf den
verbrauch um 15 prozent zu senken
nach dem motto je schneller wir handeln
je mehr wir sparen desto sicherer sind
wir die kommission will private
haushalte schützen zugleich aber den
binnenmarkt die industrie soll nur
gezielte gas sperren ertragen
lieferketten für unverzichtbare produkte
sollen weiterlaufen
energieversorger sollen zudem den
brennstoff wechseln das passiert in
höchst bei frankfurt heißen dampf für
die chemieproduktion erzeugt dieses
kraftwerk wald mit heizöl statt mit
erdgas doch dass es keine lösung
alle es gibt viele
produktionsstandorte die eben nicht die
möglichkeit haben erdgas so leicht durch
einen anderen brennstoff zu ersetzen und
dann bleibt dann wird sich nur die
produktionseinstellung die entscheidung
darüber stehe nicht in ihrer macht so
die kommission
die ganz entscheidende frage wenn es
jetzt zu einer gas mangel lage auf
europäischer ebene kommt wie denn jetzt
das gas verteilt wird wer dann noch
welches bekommt das machte die
kommission jetzt aus beantworten
sie brauche dafür mehr kompetenzen oder
die eu-mitglieder regeln die frage
selbst doch es gibt bislang nur sechs
bilaterale abkommen zum gasaustausch
dieses vakuum nutzt putin der gestern
erst versichert gazprom hat seine
verpflichtungen bislang erfüllt erfüllt
sie jetzt und wird sie immer erfüllen
und im selben atemzug behauptet das sei
nicht möglich wegen eu-sanktionen in
diesem spiel klärt die eu besser schnell
wer den mangel verwaltet ein
verteilungskampf wäre zu putins vorteil
bürgergeld statt hartz 4 das ist das
größte und wichtigste reformprojekt der
ampel koalition für den arbeitsmarkt
jetzt hat arbeitsminister heil eckpunkte
vorgestellt so soll das bürgergeld an
weniger auflagen geknüpft sein ein
wesentlicher punkt bleibt aber noch
offen die höhe der leistungen bei
knirscht es in der dreier koalition
im wahlkampf war es ein kernversprechen
der spd kein hartz 4 mehr dafür ein
bürgergeld heute präsentiert der
arbeitsminister sein entwurf es geht um
einen sozialstaat auf der höhe der zeit
es geht darum dass menschen die in not
sind verlässlich abgesichert werden es
eine frage der gesellschaftlichen
solidarität und das ist der plan zwei
jahre lang ist bei der berechnung egal
wie groß die eigene wohnung ist und ob
man einen größeren geldbetrag gespart
hat arbeitsvermittlung und weiterbildung
bekommen den gleichen stellenwert und
mindestens für sechs monate gilt eine
vertrauens- zeit in der gar nicht
gekürzt werden darf wieso soll das
vertrauen seien sechs monate lang
pflicht verletzungen einfach hinzunehmen
ohne jede reaktion ohne jede
leistungskürzung das ist ein einknicken
von mitwirkungs verweigerung wie hoch
das neue bürgergeld wird da müsste man
noch verhandeln und rechnen sagte der
arbeitsminister sozialverbände fordern
heute eine anhebung um mindestens 50
prozent
die bisherigen sätze reichen einfach
nicht aus und davon ein menschenwürdiges
leben zu führen das kann nicht sein dass
sich ein bürgergeld verspreche und den
menschen am ende doch noch zur tafel
gehen müssen oder flaschen sammeln
müssen die fdp sagt man müsse die
inflation ausgleichen eine anhebung der
sätze darüber hinaus so wie es heil
vorschwebt das aber sei mit ihnen nicht
zu machen der weg sollte ein anderer
sein wir sollten die integration in den
arbeitsmarkt stärken erwerbs anreize
setzen durch bessere
zuverdienstmöglichkeiten qualifizierung
chancen aber nicht darum dass wir das
umverteilungs niveau des sozialstaates
immer weiter aufblähen beim geld also
sieht es nach konflikten aus in der
ampel heil jedenfalls will das neue
bürgergeld noch in diesem jahr durchs
parlament bringen
deutschland schwitzt weiter fast überall
sind es deutlich über 30 grad die
gluthitze die gestern über dem westen
hat sich verschoben und breit gemacht
weite teile des landes von der mitte bis
zu den küsten und der osten sind tiefrot
der gestrige jahresrekord wurde heute
schon wieder übertroffen in bad
mergentheim waren es am nachmittag 40 3
grad im sonst eher kühlen hamburg
40,1 christoph distel hat details
der heißeste tag wird noch heißer im
südosten hamburgs eine lagerhalle mit
paletten und mähdreschern brennt die
feuerwehr kann die flammen nur noch in
schach halten bei extremtemperaturen
löschen die helfer in voller montur und
müssen sich dabei laufend abwechseln
schutz klamotte ist sehr sehr dick da
hält der kreislauf nicht lange durch
also nach wenigen minuten also 10 15
minuten sind die kollegen sehr erschöpft
wenn unter schwerem atemschutz
gearbeitet wird feuer rauch und da
noteinsatz so ähnlich wie hier beim
thüringischen neuendorf gab es das heute
sich mal quer durchs land oft brannte
neckar manchmal wälder zum glück
offenbar nie bis an die häuser wie viel
menschliche notfälle dieser hitze tag
gebracht hat lässt sich noch nicht
einschätzen aber ein zwischenfall bei
neuruppin wirft ein schlaglicht auf das
risiko für nutztiere
4500 hühner auf diesem transport können
weder trinken noch sich ein kühles
plätzchen suchen bei 34 grad winkt die
polizei den las daraus holt die
feuerwehr zu hilfe perle strahl bekommen
die erschöpften tiere ihre überfällige
abkühlung nach einer warnung der auf der
fahrer wieder auf die autobahn denn
selbst im hochsommer sind leben
transporte in deutschland erlaubt
auch die natur kommt heute ans limit im
alten land bei hamburg bekommen selbst
äpfel einen sonnenbrand erste braune
flecken zeigen dass sie gerade am baum
verfaulen einziges gegenmittel
künstlicher regen permanent
und während am nachmittag in sachsen
anhalt noch die luft bei gut 39 grad
über dem asphalt flimmert entladen sich
im südwesten bei stuttgart schon erste
heftige sommergewitter wetter extreme
werden langsam alltag
die hitze ist gefährlich vor allem auch
für menschen die keinen rückzugsort
haben weil sie auf der straße leben in
berlin greift man deshalb die idee der
kältehilfe aus dem winter auf mobile
helfer bieten obdachlosen schutz jetzt
eben gegen die hitze stephanie rein
berichtet
wasser in flaschen zum trinken und in
beuteln zum abkühlen in berlin machen
sich am morgen die helfer vom verein
karuna auf den weg um menschen die auf
der straße leben zu versorgen das wasser
hier kann überlebenswichtig sein die
hitze ist deswegen so gefährlich weil
man nicht selber einschätzen kann wenn
man draußen geht flaschen sammeln oder
so wie heißt du wirklich dass man
stützen ganzen tag also mandatiert
einfach die hitze ist soll fertig die
leute finden kein wird könnte ich ihnen
irgendeine wohnung gehen sich dann eine
klimaanlage an machtlosigkeit wasser ins
gesicht schütten oder so das trifft
menschen wie herbert seit zehn jahren
obdachlos in berlin zeigt er worum es
bei diesen temperaturen geht
aus und vielleicht keine ahnung luczak
30 35 grad
60-70 wirklich
wieder sauna deshalb hat das projekt
hitze hilfe in berlin schöneberg anders
als andere notunterkünfte tages geöffnet
es soll helfen die heißesten stunden zu
überstehen
die erste anlaufstelle ihrer art in der
hauptstadt für 30 obdachlose menschen es
gibt betten und duschen getränke und
essen seit montag
im ersten zwei tagen schon richtig voll
belegt sieht man dass es gebraucht wird
aber auch sehr gut angenommen wird marc
pfister und seine mitstreiter von karuna
ziehen regelmäßig los denn wenn sie
nicht kommen und nach dem menschen auf
der straße sehen kommt vielleicht keiner
zur hitzewelle in deutschland gibt es
auch ein zdf spezial um 19.20 direkt
nach unseren nachrichten nach wie vor
leiden auch andere teile europas unter
hitze und dürre besonders heftig war es
heute in griechenland in der nähe von
athen dort zerstörten buschbrände
mehrere häuser hunderte anwohner mussten
sich in sicherheit bringen auch ein
kinderkrankenhaus wurde evakuiert
am nachmittag schaffte es die feuerwehr
trotz der starken winde den brand unter
kontrolle zu bringen
zum krieg in der ukraine da hat die eu
neue russland sanktionen auf den weg
gebracht dabei geht es um den handel mit
gold aus russland und um
exportkontrollen für spitzentechnologie
außerdem wird des weiteren personen aus
putins umfeld verboten in die eben zu
reisen neue raketenangriffe trafen
mehrere städte im süden und osten der
ukraine umgekehrt gelang es der
ukrainischen armee offenbar eine für die
russischen truppen wichtige brücke über
den fluss nico schwer zu treffen
jeden tag sterben in diesem krieg
menschen auf beiden seiten und vor allem
gegnerische soldaten bekommen selten ein
grad dabei gibt es gute gründe sich auch
um die toten des feindes zu kümmern eine
ukrainische einheit mit dieser aufgabe
ist im osten des landes bei kif im
einsatz unser reporter dara hassanzadeh
konnte sie begleiten ein abstellgleis
irgendwo bei kharkiv den genauen
standort dürfen wir nicht nennen anton
führt die ukrainische militäreinheit j9
an seine aufgabe ist es gefallen
russische soldaten zu bergen die
zurückgelassen wurden
wir in unserer einheit behandeln alle
gefallenen russischen soldaten nach den
regeln des völkerrechts ich betone in
diesem punkt sind wir nicht wie die
russische armee
es geht zur not ostfront der einheit
wurde ein leichenfund gemeldet im
umkämpften gebiet hier treten schnell
und mit kleiner kamera sie wissen um die
gefahr um minen und sprengfallen mit
jedem schritt nimmt der geruch der
verwesung zu anton dokumentiert den
leichnam der tote russische soldat muss
schon sehr lange hier gelegen haben
gourmet sind ja wirklich schon so als er
russisch besetzte ortschaften befreit
hatten haben wir ein massengrab mit
russischen soldaten gefunden
es war nur eine grube in die die
leichname hineingeworfen wurden wir
haben nicht einmal ihre leichen
mitgenommen obwohl es dazu gelesen über
140 leichen gefallener russischer
soldaten hat allein die hiesige einheit
geborgen sie werden ausgetauscht gegen
ukrainische gefallen organisiert wird
das vom roten kreuz
details bleiben geheim
eine reportage aus der ukraine von dara
hassanzadeh können sie auch im
auslandsjournal sehen um 23 uhr c
wie geht's weiter in der regierungskrise
in italien das könnte sich in diesen
stunden entscheiden bei einer weiteren
vertrauensabstimmung
ministerpräsident draghi hat heute
morgen angekündigt doch im amt bleiben
zu wollen er forderte einen
vertrauenspakt zwischen den
zerstrittenen regierungsparteien
vergangene woche war die 5 sterne
bewegung aus der koalition ausgeschert
in großbritannien wird ja bereits ein
nachfolger für prämie johnson gesucht
heute haben die regierenden
konservativen entschieden welche zwei
kandidaten sich dem votum der
parteimitglieder stellen und zwar der
frühere finanzminister regie zu nec und
aussenministerin list schoss wer johnson
als parteichef und premierminister
beerbt soll dann anfang september
feststehen
dieser zwanzigster juli ist ein tag der
mahnung und des erinnerns heute vor 78
jahren scheiterte das attentat auf adolf
hitler in berlin wurden am nachmittag an
den widerstand gegen das ns regime
erinnert an der gedenkstätte plötzensee
lichten politiker kränze nieder die
belarussische oppositionelle die ich an
oskar würdigte den mut der menschen die
gegen hitler gekämpft haben zivilcourage
sei zeitlos
er selbst bezeichnete sich mal als
zickige diva regisseur dieter wedel
einst einer der ganz großen der branche
vom publikum und auch im zdf gefeiert
doch dann warfen ihm mehrere
schauspielerinnen vor sie sexuell
belästigt zu haben ein möglicher prozess
wegen vergewaltigung wird jetzt nicht
eröffnet denn wie erst heute bekannt
wurde starb dieter wedel vergangenen
freitag mit 82 jahren tobias häfner
erinnert
ich hatte ja nichts dafür sie an imbiss
einladen der schattenmann oder der große
bellheim mehrteiler die vor allem in den
90er jahren millionen menschen vor dem
fernseher versammelten waren die eine
seite von dieter wedel
zahlreiche vorwürfe narzissmus
cholerisch und am ende sogar
vergewaltigung die andere die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen ermittelt es
schon länger und ein gericht wollte
heute verkünden ob es zu einem prozess
kommt stattdessen die mitteilung vom tod
geboren wird wedel in frankfurt am main
er studiert später und erlebt an der
schauspielschule einen wendepunkt ich
konnte mein ich kann meine gefühle auch
im leben nicht zeigen konnte sogar nie
auf der bühne wenn dann vorsprechen
waren war das schlechteste und dann hat
mir ein
schauspieler den regisseur der
durchbruch in den siebzigern mit der
satire um die durchschnittsfamilie
semmeling mit der zeit entwickelt dieter
wedel einen eigenen stil deutsche star
power in filmen die den finger oft in
gesellschaftliche wunden legen sein
perfektionismus macht ihn erfolgreich
aber auch berüchtigt
er treibt schauspieler an ihre grenzen
und manchmal auch darüber hinaus für
mich ist ein film wie eine große
elektrische eisenbahn und ich darf alles
bestimmen und
versuche auch natürlich die zimbel und
die kontrolle in der hand sein auch das
privatleben eine achterbahnfahrt sechs
kinder von sechs frauen darunter etwa
die schauspielerinnen hannelore elsner
2018 dann veröffentlicht die zeit die
vergewaltigungs vorwürfe vor gericht
aufgearbeitet werden sie nun nicht mehr
und jetzt fußball wm der frauen in zwei
stunden beginnt das erste viertelfinale
gegen spanien norbert wer favorit ja
klar die gastgeberinnen nach dieser
grandiosen vorrunde mit drei siegen in
drei spielen und 14 zu 0 toren ja und
dann ist da auch noch die zwölfte frau
im stadion nämlich das völlig frauen
fußball verrückte publikum land die
hitzewelle überstanden nun heißt es für
die fans der englischen löwen in
brighton wahrmachen heiß auf den titel
sind sie schon sie müssen das turnier
gewinnen auf jeden fall
aller zeiten ich bin euphorisch england
mit dem finale stehen eine fast
überirdische vorrunde mit toren wie am
fließband plus heimvorteil gegen bislang
farblose spanierin wäre alles außer ein
sieg der fußballwelt untergang die
größte sorge bei den löwinnen corona vor
sechs tagen wurde coach carina wiegmann
positiv getestet die befürchtete welle
durchs team blieb aus am nachmittag
entwarnung ein negativer test der
star-coach mit dabei band vom gegner
natürlich fehlen ihnen zwei
schlüsselspielerinnen verletzt aber das
team ist sehr stark unheimlich
ballsicher aber im spiel gegen
deutschland haben wir auch
schwachstellen gesehen nicht in die
favoriten ecke drängen lassen doch
spanien muss hoffen dass die löwen ihr
pulver schon verschossen habe
er gelernt gegen spanien gleich bei uns
im zdf zu sehen ab 20 25 in sport studio
live ja und morgen dann das deutsche
viertelfinal spiel gegen österreich das
dfb team nach der ebenfalls makellosen
vorrunde hoch motiviert und mit guten
nachrichten was das personal betrifft
torjägerin schüler erstmals nach corona
infektion wieder dabei gestern in einer
nicht allzu intensiven trainingseinheit
am heißesten tag aller zeiten im
großraum london wie die radiosender
stündlich verkündeten die anschließend
geburtstag machten daher nur die hitze
erprobte ssten mit das war jetzt auch
sehr wichtig gerade nach den ersten drei
sehr anstrengenden spielen dass wir da
auch jetzt vor allen dingen einen tag
mehr noch frei hatten was auch die
zuletzt angeschlagenen lina magull gut
tat lediglich ersatz torfrau schuld
dürfte wegen eines infekts ausfallend
ansonsten sind alle anderen 22
spielerinnen stand heute spielfähig und
ich hoffe dass das morgen auch noch so
der fall ist ganz so heiß wird's dann
nicht mehr sein
packendes spitzenduell heute auf der
siebten etappe der tour de france
nach 130 kilometern gewinn
titelverteidiger ta dp jha den
zielsprint vor dem gesamtführenden jonas
wigger der däne weiterhin im gelben
trikot der slowene programm weiterhin
zweiter in der gesamtwertung
und der berliner simon geschke weiterhin
bester in der bergwertung und alles auch
bald ziemlich erhitze
wir noch die lottozahlen sie lauten 2 3
36 42 43 49 und die superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
und der deutsche wetterdienst warnt
aktuell vor schweren gewittern mit
hagelschlag im süden baden württembergs
und auch die nacht bleibt vielerorts
gewittrig die weiteren aussichten hat
gleich katja honnefer das heute journal
mit christian sievers in der
halbzeitpause gegen 10 vor 10 danke für
ihr interesse machen sie sich noch einen
schönen abend und bis morgen wenn sie
würden auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend hitze hoch jährigen wird
jetzt abgedrängt von dem tief caroline
das bringt kräftige schauer und gewitter
mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen und
zusammen mit dem hoch klaus wird es
morgen im nordwesten deutschlands dann
merklich kühler jetzt nicht nach gibt es
zwei gewitter schwerpunkte zum einen in
baden-württemberg und in bayern und zum
anderen hier im nordwesten besonders
diese gebiete im nordwesten die können
sehr heftig ausfallen die ziehen nur
ganz langsam auch dazwischen gibt es
einige regenschauer und trocken bleibt
es zwischen der ostseeküste und dem
erzgebirge dort bleiben die
nachttemperaturen tropisch sinken also
nicht unter 20 grad sonst wird es bei 19
bis 15 grad schon ein bisschen
angenehmer und morgen gibt es
hochsommerliche werte bei 25 bis 32 grad
im nordwesten aber ist's kühler mit 21
bis 24 grad das liegt eben an diesen
heftigen gewittern an dem kräftigen
regen der sich nur ganz allmählich
ostwärts weiter wälzt freund hier sieht
es an der ostsee aus um zwischen dem
thüringer wald im oberrhein und der
moose dann kommt der freitag der wird
erst mal freundlich seien in der nacht
zu samstag an dann neue gewitter heran
die uns samstag dann ostwärts überqueren
der sonntag wird für alle freundlich bei
bis zu 34 grad guten abend